[Music]
the bell's
already been wrong
and they've heard it
but in the dark among the stars
ding dong the god is dead
welcome to the hall of heroes
on august 22nd comes an unprecedented
global fan event
hello everybody it's all dc all the time
dc fandom is unlike anything you've ever
seen before
i'm actually standing inside a stage
that jim lee himself
drew how incredibly cool is that it's
crazy right
this worldwide mega event is for dc fans
across the globe
guten tag manaflander we've got
exclusive footage
insider info the latest dc news and huge
announcements
you know what i'm talking about there
was no way that i could come here and
not bring a look at the movie
yes yes there's so
much cool content to look at that was a
really special episode
designed just for you the absolute dc
fan it's amazing
there's something that i can show you
exclusive content stuff that seems
impossible ends up becoming
possible i am beyond excited to be
sharing this moment with you guys
awesome hang on tight cause we are about
to whisk you around the dc fandom
are you guys ready let's get this thing
started
dc fandom hall of heroes all fans
welcome
24 hours only august 22nd and there's
only
one place you can experience it at
dcfandome.com
you